all right we have um a diverse range of
the participants so afroza is from my
Pharmacy background deeksha is a
research scholar at Kappa Institute of
engineering and Technology
can you guys also let me know what are
your research interests and
with respect to infectious disease is
there any particular area that you would
like to learn more about
and what about the rest of you guys
um Julia Kishore Muhammad Samuel
I'm curious to know about you guys as
well
foreign
thank you
yes of course
I would like to
know more about skin infection
as you know skin infection take very
lightly in our country but
when I uh
learn about infection and I was making a
cross-sectional study in last year
where I uh where I observed most of the
girls
especially women are infected by skin
infection and they were on your about
death
so
I would like to know more about these
infection and its uh
it's no Botanical treatment
which is which is available in our
villages
and uh
also cheap costing
all right thank you so much for
introducing your background and your
interests I'm sure this uh today's uh
webinar will be helpful for you to learn
more about the program
and
um what about the rest of you guys
uh all right diksha says she is
interested in immuno informatics and
Kishore
um is Dr Kishore a PhD in molecular
biology and it's a passionate
academician who work on HIV and
antimicrobial resistance and it's new in
the field event thank you so much Dr
Kishore
and what about the rest of you
if you're not able to unmute yourself
and think you can let me know in the
chat as well
we'll be starting in just a four more
minutes
we are starting to get some queries will
you be providing recording of the
fashion
uh yes we will be recording thank you
for uh responding expression
uh what about the rest of you I'm
monitoring the chat box for your
responses
we have a diverse range of background uh
participants from diverse range of
backgrounds
uh so for those participants who are
just joined uh we'll be starting with
the webinar in just few more minutes and
meanwhile we are waiting
um it would be great if you could
introduce yourself in the chat box if
you have the participants have already
uh introduced themselves I'm curious to
know about the rest of you as well
all right uh can the participants
um confirm with uh
you can see my screen
okay so let's get started with today's
webinar so hello everyone a very warm
greeting to one and all my name is
I would like to welcome you all to the
webinar on omix logic find Matic
infectious disease program
this program is dedicated to the study
of Byron diversity and its role in
academic infectious diseases that keep
re-emerging including zoonotic pillow
Transmissions between humans and the
process of viral and bacterial disease
development and as a result you will
learn to understand relationships
between viral strains and haplotypes
find differences in sequence data and
see the implications for drug and
vaccine design this program will provide
opportunities to practice analyzing data
to gain hands-on experience with curated
data sets from public domain collections
Guided by experts with bioinformatics
experience and knowledge about virology
so before we begin with today's webinar
let me also take a brief moment to
introduce you to the team behind the
program we are a us-based diet company
who is working with multiple academic
and Commercial collaborators to develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission is to make client marriage more
accuracy
and as a part of our mission our team is
working with local and regional
coordinator that are helping refine
local program Logistics and adapting
them to the needs of students and
researchers around the world and this
training has been completed by over 24
000 participants from 187 countries in
over 300 workshops in six different
specialization tracks that include
oncology infectious diseases Precision
medicine Neuroscience data science for
biomedical data and as a part of the
training you will have access to the
omic storage resources which takes a
combination of training modules data
analysis tools curated project data sets
and interactive sessions with mentors to
give the student a clear part of the
boom's taxonomy pyramid
and this also comes with an access to
the owner started courses
which includes courses on bioinformatics
Precision medicine multi-amer that
consists of genomic transatomic
metagenomic and epigenomic data science
that includes bioinformatics using R in
python as well as chemical format
and example projects of different fields
which you could learn from and replicate
for your research
the omics logic platform also gives
options for analyzing a given data set
for instance you can learn
bioinformatics without any coding at all
for those interested in opting the
non-code pathway they will be given
directions to access the T by Uncle
platform for bioinformatic processing
and Analysis of data the platform
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management and Analysis Cloud
infrastructure to run the bioinformatic
pipeline and different stages analysis
are performed in different sections on
this multi-atomic path
and for those interested in learning to
analyze data through coding we provide
the omex logic code playground which
will help you develop coding skills
while learning popular packages in our
programming and python to visualize
annotate and analyze complex patterns in
biological data
so now to view the various courses and
example projects and student projects
you need to first sign up on the omics
logic loan table before that let me walk
you through a brief demo on what a
completed profile on the portal looks
like so once you sign up on the portal
these are the features that you need to
update on your account that is a
completed profile will have a profile
image full name with appropriate
capitalization link to your social media
handle a brief bio about yourself that
will consist of your education
background and Research into it the
mentors can view your progress under the
activity tab the courses you are
currently completing will appear under
the core system and finally after the
completion of your coursework the
certificates will appear under the
certificate
so with that let us Begin by signing up
on the project learn portal before we
move ahead with today's webinar
so I'm pasting the link for signing up
in the chat box so for those
participants who have not signed up on
the portal please take a moment to sign
up and I'll show you the various courses
and example projects that we'll be
making use of as part of the program
so for those participants who are
creating an account I'll show you a
brief demo on how you can do that for
that please click on the create an
account option that you see here and
when you click on this you will have the
option to uh create an account using by
one method is by entering your name
email ID and password or you can also
sign up using any of your social media
handles this could be your Google
Facebook Apple account GitHub account or
even Twitter so you can simply sign sign
up using any of your social media
handles as well and that will directly
take you to the portal courses
so with that I'll pause for a couple of
seconds for the participants to sign up
and once you have signed up please put a
yes in the chat box so that I know I can
proceed further
and I can see that some of the
participants are familiar and are
joining us for
um for a second or third time so such
part of them can put it done as well
that you already have uh an account on
the portal so that I can know that as
well
[Music]
have you guys started signing up please
put a response in the chat so that I can
proceed further
all right Dr Kumar has logged in
foreign
all right so meanwhile you guys are
signing up I'm just going to proceed
ahead and log into my account so that I
can proceed ahead with the webinar so
since I already have an account on the
portal I'm just going to click on the
sign in not sign in option
so once you sign up you will be able to
see the courses picture so under the
courses page when you scroll down below
you will see a search bar that says
looking for a specific course so here if
you are to enter any of your uh
interested area or research you can just
enter the keyword related to that so
let's say uh build most of the
participants who are interested in
infectious diseases when you type the
word infectious disease you will see the
various courses and example project that
makes use of the concept so for example
we have a example project on
tuberculosis infection and treatment and
then we have a host response to malaria
infection and covid-19 project and so on
so you can take a look at it at your own
pace I I'm just going to proceed ahead
and show you how you can set up your
account on the portal first so for that
uh on the blue bar at the top click on
the tab that goes welcome back with your
email ID
when you click on that you will be able
to see your account settings here you
will be able to edit your profile when
you click on the tab that on the icon
that's this profile it will show you the
uh it will enable you to edit several
features make sure that once like I
mentioned in my presentation that your
name is important capitalization and you
upload a profile image for yourself add
a bio as well that consists of your
education background and research in
depth and link your social media habits
as well and like I mentioned under the
activity tab the community manager and
the program Mentor they will be tracking
your learning progress under the courses
tab they'll be tracking your report
you'll be able to track your courses for
example recently I've been taking up
chronic analysis in Python course
and uh once you complete a project and
publish it on our portal that will be
displayed under the project Tab and when
you enroll for the program that will be
displayed under the program stack along
with the progress that you're making and
finally once you complete the courses
with the required assignment answers
you'll be able to receive the
certificate under the certificate
and another interesting
um tab that I want to show you is the
project tag on the top
so when you click on this you will be
able to see the various student projects
that have been completed uh and
published on the portal so here you'll
see a diverse range of top uh project
ranging from oncology Precision medicine
neuroscience and amongst it is are
several projects on infectious disease
as well so similarly you can just enter
the keyword infectious disease and
you'll be able to take a look at those
as well so you can navigate through all
of this at your own pace so now let's
start with uh today's
webinar and for that I would like to
pass on the stage to Mr Ojo sweet who
will be playing a recent recording from
Mr Iya Broski who will be explaining
um an introduction to the intellectual
disease program and an overview about
this the overdue
yeah thank you do let me know once I
share my screen
[Music]
yes uh it's not loaded up yet
can you try sharing now
oh yeah I'm just trying to
okay
we have a query from Kishore in the
meantime but the webpage is taking time
to go uh no worries uh once you have um
signed up you can put your response in
the chat and uh if it is taking more
time then you can let us know and we
will be happy to look into them after
and um what about the rest of you have
you guys signed up as well
all right thank you so much
yes or just so we can see your screen
it's loading up
informatics is used in the study for
infectious diseases coming from
different types of pathogens and what
we'll do is we'll introduce you to
curated examples
of how you can analyze data where to
find such data and how to make
conclusions
okay so uh what I'll do in my part of
the presentation is I will review some
of the introductory material about the
program then I will pass it on to uh Dr
raghavendran Who is going to review some
of the Practical things of how you can
get started with some of the types of
data that is usually used for these
kinds of studies
so bioinformatics for infectious
diseases is a program that is designed
for biologists clinicians students that
are interested in virology microbiology
and Immunology
that would like to learn how to apply
bioinformatics to different types of big
data for research and applications about
infectious diseases to design novel
diagnostic approaches to understand how
antiviral and antimicrobial drugs are
being designed how vaccines are relying
on data and bioinformatics to address
new and maybe potentially in the future
upcoming disease outbreaks and also how
to understand what are some of the
important challenges and questions that
remain to be answered and how
bioinformatics can help us address those
as well
so what I'll do is I'll first explain
how some of the questions about
infectious diseases are related to
bioinformatics
you know if we can think about this
program as just a series of questions
that one can ask and use bioinformatics
to find potential answers
one question might be what is a pathogen
what differentiates pathogens from
non-pathogens what differentiates for
example bacteria that coexist together
with humans plants and other hosts from
those that cause disease
how can that help us understand the
evolution or the conditions of
competition that caused these
microorganisms to evolve share recipes
uh kind of record what works and how to
adapt what they the tools that they have
to overcome different types of
challenges
another question can be where do
diseases come from how come is it that
some diseases persist and some diseases
have these outbreaks that are acute that
have a beginning that have an end where
do they come from
how do we understand the origins of
diseases like coronavirus or Ebola or
other diseases that cause these endemic
or pandemic outbreaks
how can we understand this in the
context of interaction between different
hosts for example different species
humans their pets the different cattle
that we grow how can that be a source of
Novel pathogens
what is the actual disease that they
Cause right how can we describe the
reaction of the host to the pathogen as
a condition that we can diagnose so what
makes that as a disease and what you can
think of all of these microorganisms as
essentially parasites that leverage some
of the resources that the hosts have
accumulated leverage their mechanisms of
production of vital proteins to be able
to replicate themselves
and how they as a result of hijacking
some of these resources can also cause
toxicity and disruption of the host
function
we'll also talk about how diseases
spread because what characterizes an
infectious disease or a communicable
disease and sets it apart from other
types of diseases which are commonly
known as chronic diseases like cancer
for example or hypertension is the fact
that they're caused by pathogen and that
pathogen is a transmittable pathogen you
can actually share it between
individuals and so when we think of that
transmission and the pattern of
transmission we can also use
bioinformatics to understand the
population scale how does the population
react to a disease for example herd
immunity yeah or how does the population
become susceptible for example having
similar characteristics within a
particular group or a population how can
that make them more susceptible to a
particular types of diseases
and we'll also talk about the balance of
replication how
while a pathogen causes acute disease
oftentimes one of its objectives is to
continue and replicate and find a
balance where it can continue to
replicate and spread between many
individuals causing them to potentially
have mild condition that does not
prevent it from continuing to replicate
then we'll talk about how to treat or
prevent disease and we'll talk about how
novel advanced
answers are examples of bioinformatics
in part because understanding the
particular situations where vaccines can
be more adapted to the specifics of the
pathogen and maybe novel antivirals
could be designed based on our
understanding of the interaction between
the host and the pathogen can lead to
novel ways to treat disease but we'll
also talk about how early Diagnostics or
understanding specifically what pathogen
and what strain of a pathogen or maybe a
variant of a pathogen is causing a
disease is critical for the future of
these kinds of interventions because as
we will see in the last portion what
remains to be done
we'll see how the same principles of
evolution can help us understand how the
diseases that are caused by pathogens
are only preventable if we can develop
systems of early detection and
understanding of the evolution that they
undergo because we can identify a
precise variant and we can treat that
precise variant but we don't always know
how to anticipate novel variants and to
anticipate novel variants and design
Therapeutics that can potentially
co-evolve with these pathogens their new
strategies and novel understanding about
how these types of uh discoveries can
really help us anticipate and prevent
future outbreaks
so in the context of this particular
online program what we have prepared on
our side are a number of examples or
let's call them case studies
case studies where we can take curated
data sets and start designing
bioinformatics projects where we have a
question we have a data set and then we
have a path to answer that question from
that data set or methods of analysis of
data that could inform some of our
understanding of the answers to these
questions so what are some of these case
studies and data sets one of them is
going to be about the Ebola outbreak in
2014 to 2016. now what's interesting
about this outbreak is that it is one of
the first examples
where large-scale genomic sequencing was
employed almost in real time to track an
epidemic to understand how the epidemic
is spreading in a particular region and
then use this understanding to design a
vaccine in an antiviral drug
another example that we're going to look
at is going to speak about
the spread of covet 19. and when we
think about covid-19 we obviously hear
so much about it in the news but what is
exceptionally I think kind of for
bioinformaticians is interesting in this
pandemic specifically is that the amount
of data and the detail of data is now uh
very rich and and very precise being
updated almost in real time from many
different regions so really the scale of
the data collection here is unheard of
in any other kind of disease not only
that this particular pandemic has
popularized some of the terms that we
rely on as bioinformations to understand
how genomes of particular pathogens or
how molecular biology and and kind of
the background of how these pathogens
cause disease are really becoming
understood by even the general public so
today everyone understands what a
variant or a mutation is everyone
appreciates the ability to study some
genomic pattern and try to make
inference that has a practical
application we don't have to explain the
need to understand and maybe sequence
some of these pathogens because now
everyone is in tune with this scientific
Endeavor to try to really understand how
this pathogen is evolving right we don't
need to explain that it is evolving
right everybody knows that so really
we're going to take a look at some of
those data sets in this as well
another example that we will look at is
the development of vaccines to address
the kind of chronic or endemic
plasmodium forciparum uh um spread in
Africa and in South Asia and we'll take
a look at how genomic surveillance and
understanding of both resistance to some
of the known drugs that are used to
treat plasmodium as well as the efforts
to design an effective vaccine that
turns out to be a non-trivial effort
that requires a deep understanding of
genomic variability across different
regions and the understanding of how
that genomic variability can be used or
leveraged to really find an effective
way to interfere
we'll also look at how
uh viruses are not only
um the result of these kinds of acute
outbreaks of infectious diseases but
we'll also see how there's a greater
appreciation of the role that viruses
play in other types of diseases for
example in neurodegenerative diseases
like multiple sclerosis
where maybe an exciting idea resulting
from this observation is that if we
treat the virus if we find a way to
treat the virus the viral infection we
don't have to deal with the symptoms
with the consequences that are the
outcome of this persistent infection
leading to these long-term deterioration
of the cognitive function we'll also
take a look at how these types of
observations are relevant in diseases
like cancer where abstain virus and
others have been found to play a major
role in the onset and maybe development
of these cancers so I think really
infectious diseases now is going from
some of these prominent case studies
that we're going to take a look at like
Ebola malaria and covid and even extend
to some of the non-typically considered
as infectious diseases but chronic
diseases that potentially have a
connection to viral pathogens and others
we'll also look at some of the
challenges that still remain to be
addressed even though
we think of treatments like antibiotics
for example as an established way to
treat disease that have been very
successful over the past several decades
these kinds of inter
preventions are new our ability to
design vaccines and adapt them to
particular pathogens is something that
happened in the past maybe decade our
ability to leverage the antibiotics to
treat these bacterial diseases is also
just a few decades old and as a result
of widespread use of these types of
interventions we're also seeing the
reverse reaction right where we are
seeing how these types of interventions
can become weaker over time as a result
of evolution and adaptation we see
emergence of resistance and drug
resistant tuberculosis for example is a
major risk we can see uh novel pathogens
bacterial pathogens that are emerging in
hospitals that are not possible to treat
with antibiotics we're also seeing novel
variants of these viral diseases that
also do not respond well to vaccines
that were designed so really these are
some of the challenges that continue to
emerge in these kinds of effective ways
to leverage bioinformatics and we'll
talk about where we can find some data
sets and what are some of the methods of
analysis that we can leverage to try and
answer some of these questions and
challenges
now where can you find some of these we
have designed a portal where our team
has curated uh project examples and
tutorials that you can leverage as an
independent learner as someone who just
wants to obtain some bioinformatics
skills or as someone that would like to
apply some of the bioinformatics skills
to a particular research question and so
those are some of the things that you
will find on the portal and I will
explain today how you can leverage this
portal more effectively in the context
of this online training portal that is
going to provide you with live sessions
as well as some of these online
resources that you can leverage to
really Master some of these skills and
practice them on particular examples
so to talk about this I'll speak about
where you can find a particular resource
that you might be interested in how you
can find different categories or even
collections of different courses and
we'll see how to get started now Beyond
this I want to mention that what you
will hear in this program is going to be
based on tutorials that were prepared in
collaboration with a number of experts
in this domain so really what we did is
we worked with the number of researchers
that are actively investigating
um all of these topics from the
perspective of pure bioinformatics or an
algorithmic perspective how to design
methods to analyze such data effectively
we've worked with researchers that
specialize in some of these pathogens
and have been performing research in the
area of malaria or coronaviruses for a
long time and also people that apply the
bioinformatics to connect the biological
questions with the specific data sets
that are available and are being
extended and populated with these new uh
viral and bacterial genomes or even
parasite genomes in the case of malaria
to try and answer these questions
comprehensively so we'll leverage their
expertise and we'll present to you some
of the findings and and questions and
solutions that they have identified
so what is this program all about this
program bioinformatics for infectious
diseases is going to help you understand
pathogens and the diseases that they
cause where they come from what are the
processes that cause uh the different
types of changes in their genomes that
we can observe how can they cause
infection and how can that infection
cause disease we'll also talk about the
specific ways to analyze such data a lot
of this data is going to be focused on
the understanding of genomic variability
and how to identify specific genomic
variants and characterize them in terms
of their impact on the pathogen itself
on the interaction between the pathogen
and the host and potentially on the
intervention in that interaction
we'll also talk about how you can apply
some of these principles to study a
variety of different curated data sets
identify the questions that are
important for these data sets and then
use the data sets and the methods that
we describe to find answers to these
important questions and again you will
have access to some resources that will
make your life easier if you're just
getting started but also for those of
you that are already more advanced we
will help you connect the dots and
really apply these methods in an
effective way
now the program is going to help you by
leveraging two prime primary resources
that I want to introduce briefly before
we begin the first of all of them is
going to be our big data analysis
platform some of these data sets are
going to be exceptionally large we're
going to leverage hundreds if not
thousands of genomes at a specific time
we're going to look at complex data like
RNA sequencing even single cell RNA
sequencing and so to facilitate some of
the educational aspects of our
interaction we're going to rely on this
platform that I'm going to demonstrate
in just a few moments the other part is
of course are omics logic portal that I
already briefly mentioned but I want to
highlight the significance of this
online resource because it provides a
collection of elements that are going to
be useful as you start in this
particular program and continue after
that so that you can understand the high
level overview in a short program like
we have today but then continue by
leveraging some of the specific
technical tutorials to really expand and
practice and master these skills so that
you are independent and confident in the
way that you apply them
thank you so much for playing that
recording so now uh for more details
about how you can enroll for the program
and the session details on fee structure
I would like to pass on the stage to Mr
shubham Kumar
overtuition
thank you sugary hello everyone I am
shubham the business development in
marketing theater I'll be briefly
explaining about the registration
process for the Infectious Disease
program
so just a second I'm sharing my screen
[Music]
yes we can see your screen
all right so as you can see on the
screen that this is the program page of
uh like upcoming program Infectious
Disease by informatics research and
applied genomics and here you can see
the date that it will commence from 17th
Feb and only few days are left for the
enrollment part
when you will scroll down you will see a
program overview section here you will
be getting to know about what all the
topics and Concepts you will be learning
by going through this program like the
transmission between humans and the
process of viral at disease development
you will also get to learn about the
relationship between the viral strains
and apart from that you will be working
on some of the project examples so that
you will get a hands-on experience of
how to work with the data sets available
on the public domain
when you will scroll when you will come
down you will see an interactive uh like
you will see a calendar some of the
dates highlighted like 17 21 and 24 and
on the left hand on right hand side of
that you will see what all topics we
will be covering on that particular date
like on Feb 17 which is the first
session we will be taking the laptop
like the Next Generation sequencing
viral genome in host transcriptom and
these are the topics you can see we will
be covering
and on similarly on the next session we
will be working uh we will be going
through multiple sequence alignment and
phylogeny and you will see I get to see
here when we will scroll down a bit more
uh you will find that we
have three different tenures for this
program one is for 45 days 60 days and
90 days so the uh the common resources
for all these three tenures are like
online tutorials project examples you
will be getting a Hands-On coding
sessions also and by chance if you miss
of your session then we will provide you
with the recordings
apart from that you will get the
complete Mentor support and technical
support and after the completion of this
program or your tenure we will provide
you with this certificate and also you
will get uh access for the T by info
server from where you can go uh you can
like run your data and analyze your data
and the extra feature for the 60 days is
uh you win a one-on-one mentorship
mentorship session
and track to clear up your doubts or to
work on your research project even
though you can discuss with a mentor for
your research proposal and after that
you
[Music]
presentation and for the 90 days apart
from these benefits we will be getting
an extra time to work on your research
project and get it published in the
peer-reviewed journal also
now coming to the uh pricing part uh you
uh as you can see here for the 45 days
in INR it is 7 500 for 60 days it is 9
triple nine and for 1990 days it is 14
triple nine let's say if someone who is
residing in U.S so you will find a drop
down here where you can simply click and
select your currency like uh in USD
you will see the pricing uh like 45 for
150 and for 60s it is 300 and for 90 it
is 450. now to know more about the
benefits of 90 days and the project
examples
she will be telling you about the
projects and Hands-On experiences over
to you sonalika
thank you so much let me share my screen
can you confirm that my screen is
visible
you can see your screen
thank you a very warm good morning good
evening or good afternoon and whichever
part of the world you are I am sonalika
Ray bioinformatics project manager at
buying biotech and I would like to
discuss about the applications and areas
of research in the field of infectious
diseases examples of infectious diseases
research data repositories for
infectious diseases and we'll also
discuss about some case studies on the
portal and some outcomes of the research
fellows projects on infectious diseases
infectious diseases or the research
plays a very crucial role in
understanding the prevention and control
of these diseases I would like to
discuss some examples of the application
and areas of research in the field to
begin with the first field is vaccine
development Research into infectious
diseases is critical for the development
of vaccines to prevent their spread for
example researchers are currently
working on developing vaccines for
diseases such as over 19 Ebola and zika
virus
then comes anti-microbial resistance AMR
is a growing problem and Research into
infectious diseases is essential for
understanding the mechanisms of
resistance and developing strategies to
prevent it
one of the applications is also to
design or develop diagnostic tools
Research into infectious diseases is
crucial for this development of rapid
and accurate diagnostic tools or tests
for disease detection
for example researchers are currently
working on developing point of care
diagnostic tests for diseases such as
tuberculosis and HIV
for epidemiology and surveillance as
well infectious diseases research plays
a very crucial role
as the spread of infectious diseases is
essential for their control and
prevention the research helps to do the
same for example researchers are
currently studying the spread of
covid-19 to understand its transmission
Dynamics and develop effective control
measures
for host and pathogen interactions
Research into these interactions between
pathogens and their host organisms is
essential for understanding the
mechanisms of disease and developing
effective treatments
Research into the immune responses to
infectious diseases is essential for
understanding how the body defends
itself against these diseases and
developing immunotherapies to treat the
same
also Research into the prevention and
control of infectious diseases is
essential for developing effective
strategies to reduce their impact on
public health for example researchers
are currently studying the effectiveness
of measures such as social distancing
contact tracing and Mast wearing to
control the spread of covet 19.
and last but not the least one health
approach that recognizes the
interconnection between human health
Animal Health and the environment and
Research into infectious diseases often
takes a one health approach to
understanding the transmission of these
diseases between different species
infectious disease research often
focuses on specific pathogens or
organisms that cause the disease
I would like to discuss few examples of
infectious disease studies with these
organisms
the first one is malaria
research on malaria focuses on the
parasite plasmodium which is transmitted
to humans by the bite of infected
mosquitoes studies aim to understand the
biology of the parasite and develop
strategies for prevention and control
another one tuberculosis tuberculosis is
caused by the bacterium mycobacterium
tuberculosis and research focuses on
understanding the biology of the
bacterium and developing new treatments
and diagnostic tools
or influenza that is caused by the
influenza virus and research focuses on
understanding the biology of the virus
developing vaccines and monitoring its
Evolution to predict future outbreaks
HIV AIDS that is caused by the human
immunodeficiency virus and research
focuses on understanding the virus
developing treatments and developing a
vaccine
Ebola
is another type of a research domain or
a track that one could work on Ebola
that is caused by the Ebola virus and
the research focuses on understanding
the biology of the virus developing
treatments and vaccines and studying the
diseases impacts on the community the
Ebola virus is a zoonotic disease
meaning it spreads between animals and
humans in this case from fruit bats to
humans once in humans it easily spreads
from person to person through contact
with blood and other body fluids the
genomic analysis revealed that current
version of the virus in West Africa most
likely spread from middle Africa within
the past 10 years they also found that
the viruses causing this outbreak and
the two previous months diverged from a
common ancestor around 2004. this means
that this these outbreaks arose from
different jumps from animal Reservoir to
the human population
the initial case or index patient was
reported in December 2013 and 18 month
old boy from a small village in Guinea
is believed to have been infected by
bats after five additional cases of
fatal diarrhea occurred in that area an
official medical alert was issued on
January 2014 to The District Health
officials and another interesting
infectious disease that is most
researched on is
it is cost covid-19 is caused by the
SARS scope to virus and research focuses
on understanding the biology of the
virus and also developing treatments and
vaccines and starting the disease impact
on populations and Health Care system
these are just a few examples of
infectious disease studies with
organisms the study of infectious
diseases is a rapidly evolving field a
new research is constantly uncovering
new information about the pathogens in
organisms that cause the disease
viruses are constantly evolving and
changing every time a virus replicates
or makes a copy of itself there is a
potential for there to be changes in its
structure each of these changes is a
mutation a virus with one or more
mutations is called a variant of the
original virus some mutations can lead
to changes in important characteristics
of the virus including the
characteristics that affect its ability
to spread and or its ability to cause
more severe illness and death
it is normal for viruses to change and
evolve as they spread between people
over time when these changes become
significantly different from the
original virus they are known as
variants and to identify these variants
one can imply NG sequencing to compare
the whole genome sequences and compare
it with the reference genome to see if
they have changed
a detailed comparative analysis of the
whole genome sequence like multiple
sequence and Analysis and phylogenetic
analysis or reconstruction can help us
understand the viral adaptations that
lead to increased virulence the
geographic spread of the epidemic and
various other characteristics of the
pathogen in general
for example this analysis will also
place any new strain in their respective
plates that characterizes several viral
strains this identifies the closest
relative and hence the string from which
the novel isolate could have been
evolved this can give us major Clues to
treating the infection stop its spread
as a dead during the Ebola outbreak in
African countries
so this was about some of the infectious
diseases
we would be covering few case studies
based on these different organisms in
the program and I'll just give you a
gist of what all specific case studies
they would be
before we do that let's now discuss
about some data repositories that could
be leveraged to retrieve data for
research on infectious diseases
there are many sources of data and
information on infectious diseases both
at the national and the international
level
here are some some most commonly used
data resources the first one is who
which is the leading international
Agency for public health and provides
data and information on a wide range of
infectious diseases
including reports on outbreaks and
epidemics surveillance data and
guidelines for Disease Control and
prevention the next one is CDC or the
Centers for Disease Control and
prevention the CDC is the U.S federal
agency responsible for public health and
it provides data and information on
infectious diseases affecting the U.S
population including surveillance data
guidelines for Disease Control and
prevention and resources for healthcare
providers
the third data repository European
Center for disease prevention and
control ecdc the ecdc is a European
Union agency responsible for Disease
Control and prevention in the EU and it
provides data and information on
infectious diseases affecting Europe
including surveillance data risk
assessment and guidance for Disease
Control and prevention
the fourth database or the repository
that I would like to discuss is the
pro-mate mail ProMed meal is an
electronic reporting system for
outbreaks of infectious diseases and
other public health events and it
provides real-time updates on outbreaks
and epidemics from around the world
few more repositories to discuss about
Gideon which includes Global infectious
diseases and epidemiology online Network
Gideon is an online database of
infectious diseases and it provides data
and information on the epidemiology
diagnosis treatment and control of
infectious diseases
then we have Eis that is epidemic
intelligence service of the CDC the Eis
is a training program
for public health professionals and it
provides information on emerging
infectious diseases and outbreaks as
well as training and resources for
disease surveillance and outbreak
investigation
the next database that we would explore
is nndss National
notifiable diseases surveillance system
for collecting and Reporting data on
notify on notifiable infectious diseases
in the U.S and it provides a
comprehensive picture of the incidence
and distribution of infectious diseases
in the U.S and finally we will also
explore ncbi virus that provides access
to a vast collection of biological data
including information on viruses
during the program we will discuss about
various case studies on tuberculosis
infection and treatment viral mutation
landscape study using Ultra deep
circulatory seeds so sequencing of polio
enterovirus t68 and acute flaccid
myelitis in kids and Ebola
those home enrolled for 90 days would
get an opportunity to work on research
projects with the mentors once they once
their training is complete I would like
to take you through some of the project
outcomes from our previous programs the
research fellows and also the program
participants worked on
organisms like monkeypox and sarskov too
as well and these research projects
could be found on the omics logic uh
learn portal when you click on the
projects tab we have various research
projects under the field of infectious
diseases where these researchers the
research fellows and also the program
participants try to work on an
established research on different
infectious diseases and most of them
also got some Publications and I would
like to share some Publications with all
of you these Publications were around
immunity against respect immunity
against respiratory viruses viral
genomes zika virus sarskov 2
pathogenesis polio virus virus spread
and virulence and RNA virus mutational
Fitness Landscapes these were some of
the Publications that the researchers
successfully got out after the
infections after the infectious diseases
training program
that's all that I wanted to discuss and
we will now meet you all in the sessions
and work on exciting great projects
together while making this program a
useful resource for you all thank you
everyone
if there are any questions you can
please put in the chat box our team is
still here we can help you access uh and
also get your questions clarified
thank you so much Nautica uh there is a
question from sakshin Bhatia will they
teach from scratch on how to make the
research work
yes so when you say how to work on the
research part yes we will take you from
the very basics in the training program
we will talk about these different types
of data that could be explored to work
with different types of infectious
diseases and when it comes to data
exploration or retrieval from these
repositories how do you extract the data
sets how do you prepare the data sets
and then how do you carry out the
analysis and finally how do you
interpret your results to get some
meaningful insights out of your analysis
so from the basics till the very end you
will have the mental support and we'll
take you through the research project in
this direction
yes definitely you can also work on a
parasitic organism
because this program is uh very specific
to infectious diseases so yes any of the
infectious diseases that you would like
to work on you can be it any virus or be
it any pathogenic organism
thank you so much Malika that's uh any
other parties can have any other query
uh if you'd like to like uh you can
unmute yourself and let us know as well
about your qualities
[Music]
uh Dr sudhir Kumar is asking
um since I don't know any coding will it
be a problem
no it won't it won't be a problem at all
so there are two things here if you want
to uh explore the T by info server you
can definitely do that we have uh
automated uh pipelines we have ai built
algorithms and tools in the pipelines
that you can use for your analysis I
would like to share my screen here and
quickly show you what the platform has
to offer and if you really want to use
or explore uh the scripts only for your
analysis on the specific type of disease
that you want to work with in that case
we also have R in Python Programming
courses for biomedical data or for
infectious diseases research and those
courseworks uh will teach you the
scripts from the very basic or the
beginner level so that won't be a
problem and if you are not a coding
person who does not want to uh go in
into the coding direction or use a
script for analysis says then definitely
you have the T bioinfo platform where
you have these Pipelines
which include various tools and
algorithms that could be used very
easily otherwise you would have you
would need to have a high Computing
system uh with good storage to have
these tools downloaded or installed in
your system and then use them for
analysis so in that regards using the pi
the the pipelines on the T bioinfo
server is a benefit for you where you
can process the data very easily from
the faster or the first few files that
you get from different sequencing uh
techniques and you then explore it I
won't get in too much depth right now
but uh yes you have the option to use
this uh AI built pipelines which use
different algorithms
to process your data
yes noorani once you complete the
training program and start working on
your research project you can
successfully publish your research in a
journal we would be assisting you with
your research and if you are highly
motivated to work on a research project
and get a publication out of it then
nothing can stop you
our assistance would be that
uh yes Muhammad kamran needs the contact
details
sparsh can you please share your contact
thank you you can contact Miss Pastor
she is the marketing manager she has
shared her contact number which is also
active on WhatsApp and you also have an
email address in the chat box you can
email her for any questions and sparsh
will help you get enrolled in the
program successfully
foreign
[Music]
thank you so much what about the rest of
you if uh along the way if you're having
any credit uh please feel free to reach
out to uh Spanish
um through the email ID or the contact
number that I've provided so please take
a note and keep it safe
all right then thank you so much and we
look forward to seeing you uh for the
Infectious Disease program thank you
everyone have a great day